[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen first
of all good evening to all the members
of the panel this is the overview and
scrutiny meeting 10 the 16th of February
2023 thank you panel members all for
coming up also thank you to uh officers
who are in attendance those who've come
to provide us with reports during the
course of the evening
additional counselors who are coming to
speak under all 20.1 and members of the
public
uh who are also joining us thank you
everyone for coming and joining us
um we hope you find and also those
members of the public who may be uh
tuning in this evening or watching a
little bit later uh you're very welcome
we hope you find that the meeting is a
worthwhile and informative one uh
particularly given some of the items
that are on the agenda for us to be
looking at this evening but first of all
the fire alarm procedures if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices down the main staircase opposite
the lifts in the foyer assemble in
Hawley Square on the green and officers
will assist and advise us when it's
deemed safe to return to the chamber
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
they're not used to make or receive
phone calls
um once the meeting is in progress
please note the meeting is as I
mentioned being live streamed for
members of the public it will also be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the internet but for anyone else here
does anyone intend to film the meeting
okay um I think we can jump over the
warnings and the uh about uh filming
then
um
speaking under rule 20.1 I have
initially a request from councilor
Garner to speak under rule 20.1 for
agenda item number five and agenda items
number six seven and eight councilor
Whitehead thank you for joining us for
those
um
are there any more members here
come to the bank that are impossibly
under the Prime account please thank you
very much
and this would be before the
presentation
thank you
okay thank you very much
uh any other members of public
I have received a request for public
speaking from Ms Elizabeth Wickenden she
will also be speaking on agenda item
number five and in fact I will call uh
Miss Wickenden before Council of Garner
and I think it's been explained to you
we'd like you to come forward to one of
the microphones and obviously you can
remain there until that agenda item has
been completed thank you very much
I have apologies from councilor Keane
are there any other apologies members I
think
thank you very much
decorations of Interest a gender item
number oh I beg your pardon I didn't see
that
yeah I just like to say um uh councilor
Yates is substituting for councilor Keen
thank you very much
welcome councilor Yates
Declarations of Interest any members got
Declarations of interest to make on the
agenda this evening
okay then we move to approve the minutes
of the overview scrutiny panel meeting
held on the 17th of January there is a
copy attached to the agenda pack and
most of you I'm sure will have seen it I
wasn't here for that meeting so I'm
going to ask the vice chairman who
chaired that meeting if he would mind
making the proposal and calling for a
second for those minutes to be approved
yeah thank you chair I propose those
minutes
do we have a second
thank you very much I've just checked
the minutes I assumed I was there but
I'm not I was at the meeting I'm not
very good at signing that book I'm
afraid
so I'm in attendance I was in attendance
I was present and I'm not you were
because you may just a declaration of
Interest later on in the in the meeting
that's my fault because I'm really bad
at signing that book
uh so we have a prisoner secondary our
members are you happy that
the minutes are an accurate reflection
of what went on thank you very much
um when when the signing comes can you
get
when they're signing up
a minute
okay then we're moving on to agenda item
number four
tdc's Net Zero strategy presentation we
have Dr Hannah Scott with us and as you
saw councilor bayford is also here
should there be any questions or queries
you want to bring so I'd now like to
invite Dr Scott to make her presentation
Dr Scott thank you thank you
um so this presentation was created
following a question by the chair
um around TDC around how TDC can
progress with the strategy when the high
court declared the national strategy as
not fulfilling all legal requirements
so in July 2022 so July last year a
landmark court judgment ruled that the
UK government Net Zero strategy was in
breach of the law the high court
judgment said that the strategy which
sets out plans to decarbonize the
economy does not meet the government's
full obligation under the climate change
Act
in court it emerged that the count
calculations by the civil servants to
quantify the impact of emissions cuts
from policies in the net zero strategy
did not add up to the reductions
necessary to meet the sixth carbon
budget so the sixth carbon budget is the
volume of greenhouse gases that UK is
allowed to emit between 20 33 and 37.
the challenges had noted that only 95 of
the emissions were accounted for and
therefore there was a 5 shortfall
according to the Friends of the Earth
the government will now have to update
its climate strategy
and then uh quantify how its policies
will make sure that the targets are
achieved how the climate change targets
are achieved
that updated strategy will have to be
presented to Parliament for scrutiny by
MPS
so a friend of the earth lawyer said
that it shows that climate change Act is
a piece of legislation which has teeth
and can if necessary be enforced through
our court system if the government does
not comply with its legal duties
and a base spokesperson
explained that the Net Zero stress that
strategy throw my teeth back in remains
a government policy and has not been
quashed
in fact the judge made no criticism
about the substance of their plans which
were well on track and in fact the
claimants themselves describe them as
laudable during the proceedings
so what does this mean for us
so the government strategy has not been
scrapped and is progressing well
but it will be improved for the years
2020 2033 to 37.
the ruling does not undermine the
government strategy but instead asks
that it's improved to meet the standards
of the climate change Act
and this ruling shows that the climate
change Act is enforceable and that our
Council should be taking it seriously
climate change is a threat to our health
and economy and we have pledged to
address this threat and avoid the
extreme risks
so this is the rationale behind us
writing the first TDC National the first
TDC Net Zero strategy and the TDC carbon
reduction plan
these documents lay out how we were
reaching at zero by 2030 specifically in
our Estates and core activities which is
in line with the climate change act as
well as working with others on the
thanet-wide emissions
we have not used the government strategy
to create the TDC strategy and therefore
the five percent inaccuracy in the
government's documents does not impact
on us instead the consultant's laser
energy and I created our own carbon
reduction plan specific to TDC
so
that's the that's the end of this
presentation
so my main reason for asking the
question was knowing that the meeting is
recorded it's an opportunity to give a
wider answer to members of the public
who
perhaps don't fully understand what Net
Zero is or what the targets and agents
and achievements and that are so thank
you for being prepared to come and give
this update on what has happened the
um
do any members of the committee have any
questions you wish to raise
any concerns you may have
okay thank you very much could I just
um
could I just ask for confirmation
this is another thing that I've been
asked questions about by members of the
public that tdc's carbon or Net Zero
strategy is designed
principally to affect
buildings that TDC owns and businesses
it may own the buildings that businesses
operate from in other words directly
tdc's own sphere of influence or is it
still to try and persuade
everybody
to get on board with tdc's
Net Zero strategy could I ask you that
please
yeah that's fine so
um the the Net Zero strategy actually
came to the overview in scrutiny
committee last year on the 30th of
August so it was the draft strategy back
then and then has gone to cabinet and
has now gone out to public consultation
so the document's been out since last
year and it lays out three three aspects
firstly our Net Zero pledge
so that is a reaching Net Zero within
our core Estates and activities by 2030
then by uh making sure that we reach Net
Zero by 2050 within our uh emissions
that we have partial control over and
then making sure that we also work with
others in order to uh ensure that we're
meeting the Net Zero Target to 2050 for
the whole of thanet so that's working
with the government working with
businesses and work with the community
so that is our TDC pledge that was
agreed by cabinet last year
thank you thank you very much perhaps
it's just worth saying that the
government
does have to represent uh
and that's going to happen I believe
very late March or April and then the
court will have a look at it again I
expect to ensure that they are taking
all the necessary steps
thank you uh Council Austin and I just
ask about the consultation when it ends
and are we getting good responses from
people other things that we as as
members could do to encourage more
individuals or businesses or whatever to
respond to the consultation
yes so the consultation
um has now the consultation periods
ended and we've had quite a lot of
really good responses so the report of
that so I've taken all of the responses
uh summarize the comments and then uh in
a table then explain our responses as
well there's a number of recommendations
that have come from those responses that
we uh I've taken to the climate change
CAG and the climate change KAG has
suggested that these recommendations are
good we're going to add it to the Net
Zero strategy so it's you know thanks
that everybody took part in the
consultation but this will obviously go
to Cabinet I think on the 2nd of March
to be ratified that everybody's happy
with those extra recommendations from
the public
brilliant that's great thank you and are
we going to do plenty of comms to let
members of the public know that their
ideas have been taken on board because I
think that's something that sometimes we
miss out on doing and it's really
reinforcing for members of the public to
hear that and to to know that their
ideas are are valuable to us and and we
take them seriously yeah
yeah so
um we've got the uh sorry say that again
yes yeah yeah so
um
I think working with Hannah and comms no
we did have this in our comms plan to be
able to promote it but I think as you're
saying as you're pointing out this is a
really important thing to say we took
your items on board but I think
um
what Chris is saying is that there's
this table where we've summarized the
comments and then explained to how we're
going to input that I think would be
really quite nice on the website so
everybody can see how it's been taken on
board
thank you
thank you members any other questions or
comments you'd like to make
if not thank you very much for coming
and sharing with this evening Council
bayford was there anything you wanted to
try
um I don't think so I mean I think
everybody's aware that our strategy is a
really good one you know especially lots
of favorable comments
um the changes that have been
Incorporated has been said to come into
cabinet they they will go through I'm
sure of that but I think the thing to
point out is that by and large the
comments were very positive very
supportive of the strategy and
encouraging to be honest
thank you very much Council bayford
right uh members uh thank you for coming
and sharing with us officers and if you
wish to depart for Sunday climbs that
would be fine unless you're speaking I
couldn't pull pull myself away from this
nothing Wild Horses couldn't drag me
away
okay members uh thank you we're moving
now on to agenda item number five which
is the concerns the interruption of
water supply from Southern water uh in
our region uh quite recently
um
and what uh very pleased now to welcome
uh Ms Elizabeth Wickenden to the
microphone Who as a member of our of the
public and one of our residents has
asked to speak to us this evening
notably on this item
thank you very much please just take
your time and uh we're all on the same
side here
okay thank you thank you for having me
here this evening my name is Elizabeth
Wickenden I'm a local resident I grew up
in broadstairs my first home actually
being on the silvers and the Wimpy
estate in broadstairs
um I have resided
um since then on the Wimpy estate from
August 2016 when I purchased my house
after the breakdown of my marriage I
wanted a fresh start for myself and my
two children
since moving back in 2016 there have
been as I have counted them
13 separate incidences where I am my
fellow residents have been without water
supply
and that was up to the time I sent the
letter to council Yates back in December
2022 and since then in January of 2023
alone there have been another five
further incidences of a loss of water
supply to the residents
additionally to the water outages for
the residents on the Wimpy estate there
has also been the issue of traffic
through the estate the first being a
burst water main back in December which
caused an increase in local traffic for
people getting in and out of the Wimpy
estate
further to this when the bottled water
stations were set up back in the
December loss of water this again caused
the disruption of traffic through the
estate
on one occasion when there was the burst
water main I actually had an eye
appointment which I had to cancel
because I was just sat on the estate and
not moving in the traffic
to add further insult the residents vast
majority of us still have not received
any compensation for these losses of
water especially for the December
incident when we were out without water
for a 36 hour period
from my understanding some have received
compensation others haven't and some
compensation has actually gone to
Residence in thanet who didn't even
suffer with the loss of water
the loss of water on so many different
occasions has affected local schools and
businesses I myself and a member of the
Bannon Times health club we couldn't use
the water these shower facilities
because of the loss of water which means
this interrupted when I go for a swim in
the evenings after work I'm also where a
local Junior School had to close for a
day and parents had to leave their
workplace to go and collect their
children their children from school and
take time off to look after them
I mean the loss of water really does
have a big impact on residents lives
therefore I'm asking the council tonight
to please hold Southern water to account
and ask them what their long-term plan
is for the water infrastructure in
thanet there is now an urgent sense of
Doom amongst local residents that
further new housing is being built and
will the current water infrastructure be
able to support these new developments
this is now at a critical level and
thanet District Council need to act on
behalf of residents to have this
unacceptable situation with Southern
water resolved as quickly as possible
thank you
Mr Wigan and thank you very much indeed
um could we thank you for coming
speaking but do please stay there could
you just pop the microphone off thank
you very much
um in in a moment when people have
spoken and they've been some discussion
on the matter
um it may be that that forms one of the
uh actions that we recommend uh but for
the meantime Charles could we uh
whatever else we may decide could we
make sure that we include that question
into uh the cabinet or the leader and
her discussions with Southern water to
make sure that specific question is
asked from this committee on behalf of
this book
thank you very much uh Council of Garner
please
thank you chair
um I'm sure most of us as councilors
have been contacted by residents about
the disruption caused by the growing
number of water outages across the
district in recent years especially
those of us who live in and represent
Wards in broadstairs
the run-filled water booster station
which has been at the heart of most of
the issues sits in my board on the Wimpy
estate and I've spoken to a large number
of residents there whose frustrations
and concerns were just concisely
captured in the statement from Ms
Wickenden
just now that frustration has actually
explained their frustrations have been
compounded by the incompetent way that
southern water has managed their
compensation process for last December's
lengthy outage
while some as explained while Summit
residents who went without water for
nearly two days have received nothing
others who saw No Interruption in their
service have received 100 pound plus the
company need to urgently address this
and sort it out
so Southern water Executives have many
questions to answer
and while calling them in to be grilled
by councilors on this scrutiny panel
which I'm sure you'll all be voting in
favor of
is a start What the residents of Planet
deserve is for southern water to meet
with the local community in a public
meeting for them to explain themselves a
recent petition launched by another
local resident Liz Lavin which calls for
this to happen has already attracted 850
signatures and I would hope that you
would Echo this call in your debate this
evening
with little confidence in southern
Waters infrastructure being capable of
maintaining a reliable service for the
current residents of thanet let alone
for the major housing developments
planned over the next few years we also
need to consider seeking more
information from them as a consultee in
the planning process when considering
future applications after all we would
be remiss in our responsibilities to our
residents if we were to continue granted
permission for more and more large
developments before the infrastructure
upgrades to com to cope with them were
completed thank you
Council Ghana thank you very much
uh councilor Yates you're here
substituting for Council the king am I
to assume therefore that you would like
to speak
her words as it were because she was due
to speak next on the on this item
well I think the words have to be mine
as they're coming out of my mouth but uh
yeah
um cancer Keen sends her apologies um
yeah thank you very much Liz for coming
tonight to the meeting
um
and I'm glad that the issue which has
been going on for a number of years is
finally getting the public scrutiny uh
it needs and I think southern Waters
have already said they're willing to
come to the ovian scrutiny meeting next
month so I'm hoping tonight that all all
of us as members will agree
um that that should be the right course
of action definitely
um
you've persuaded me already but uh
hopefully now the
um
uh people hearing your voice can also be
persuaded um so I think there are three
aspects of this issue from my side
there's the technical issues is and
whether the short-term Technical
Solutions are adequate enough enough and
whether there are long-term plans for
the area we don't know because the
communications like you said have been
pretty appalling
um then there's
um how can he ensure residents do
receive the compensation because it does
seem like Southern water doesn't have a
good data set and some residents are
having to be on the phone for 40 minutes
to get the compensation that they're
fully entitled to
whereas some other residents are getting
it automatically this just not a clear
response and I think we as a council
need to be providing guidance to
Residents to say this is what you
entitled to and this is how to get it
and lastly I think I've I've definitely
heard rumors that when the Wimpy estate
was built and they knew Southern water
knew the infrastructure was never
adequate enough and then when you look
at what's failed lately which is the
booster pump well the Clue's in the name
it's a booster for the pump which
probably wouldn't be needed if there was
adequate infrastructure there so
um I think my my kind of question to the
chair and potentially Democratic
Services is whether
the wording we've used
um in regards to Southern water coming
in can also cover the topics of
compensation whether it can cover the
topics of um
the adequacy of the pumping Solutions
there because from my side it'd be good
to get clarity about exactly what are in
the terms of reference for that meeting
which hopefully will agree to
um and I'll leave it there but thanks
Liz
sorry thank you Council Yates I was just
writing to make sure I got these
are you able to stay for a few more
minutes
just just before members just before I
pass this over to you can I just make
absolutely sure that I've got the
Salient points down there there's been a
lot of information shared with this and
much of it of course has has meant
really difficult times for local
residents on more than one occasion
um but we have a question that we
consider asking Southern water to uh to
hold them to account and ask them what
their longer term infrastructure plan is
did you want it to stay at longer term
or medium and longer term or immediate
medium and longer than
I mean I would think longer term because
the more development that's going to go
up across than it the the impact it's
going to have on the infrastructure so
and I know there's certain Target
building plans for the next sort of
several years so
I think longer term would be the best
thank you very much we definitely want
to avoid sort of sticking plaster
things then the the other issue that's
come up a couple of times is
compensation the way that that is being
handled or not and the third uh major
item I picked up was about a public
meeting in response to the Public's
reaction so far are those the three
members of main issues
to the committee are there any comments
councilor Austin please
thank you chair Groundhog Day I'm afraid
um we're picking up on things that
various people have said and your
comment share about the sticking plaster
at the cabinet meeting where the green
party motion about southern water and
the environment agency and asking them
for more information routinely on large
planning applications was discussed the
leader suggested that the most sensible
way to go about this might be to ask
Southern water for information on an ad
hoc basis as and when applications came
in for large developments
this surprised us because it seems an
entirely sensible idea to ask for more
information but our motion suggested
asking for more information routinely
from Southern water the environment
agency and anybody else who who might
have uh uh information to share that
would help us with decisions for our
planning committee that we believed
would be uh useful thing to have why
would you not want more information why
would you not ask for more information
why would you not do that routinely it
seemed to us to be something that would
help the planning committee and I know
there were discussions at the planning
committee last night that went on at
some length in which water supply Etc
was was a consideration
but also it seemed to us that by doing
it that way and by doing that routinely
it would actually reduce
effort for officers it would be
something that happened automatically
every time and it would provide more
information for the planning committee
many councils across the country have a
proof that we are mystified as to why we
haven't approved it here and we don't
understand why the leader suggested what
appears to us to be a sticking plaster
solution when just doing it routinely
would make a lot more sense we
understand the discussion about yes we
know that southern Waters problems many
of the problems that they've had for
example with sewage outages and so on
have been as a result of problems with
older properties but as our speaker has
highlighted and Council Yates has
confirmed we know that there's going to
be a lot more building planned in the
area in the future it cannot but have
some kind of of impact and the question
about infrastructure plans is absolutely
crucial why are we not asking for that
routinely as part of our planning
committee deliberations thank you
thank you Council Austin Council wing
drop on that because I was on that very
long planning meeting last night and it
was really great to hear from uh
residents and and local councilors who
had a bit more insight into one
particular planning application where
they identified some flooding
so I took the leaders kind advice to ask
Southern water a planning meeting and I
asked that question about you know I've
been in two Southern water meetings
where they've clearly said we're not the
statutory body but if we're asked we
will report
and uh so we're push in an open door it
would seem and utterly failed to make
that happen last night where there was a
significant issue over flooding it's
interesting thank you for your thank you
for giving information as well it's
really valuable to have uh
information from residents about things
and just listening to you talk have we
got an issue with burst pipes there
because it seems pretty ironic that
we've had a whole series of burst pipes
on one particular uh fairly new estate
and does that point to a really bad
planning application and substandard
work on your site that is that's led to
a repeated breakdown of burst pipes so
that's one thing that I think could be
investigated by who I've no idea and I
will go back to uh what I tried to press
at the at the cabinet meeting where I
spoke under 20.1 is we have a long-term
issue if you look at our housing numbers
and I will repeat I found a document
that was commissioned by TDC in 2021
that clearly stated our population
growth up to 2040 is going to be 10 now
if you look at the the the expected
number of percentage of housing or
numbers of housing that the government
has forced upon us because there is a
mythical colleague there's a mythical
way of working out but nobody seems to
be able to explain or show me where this
this equation of working out numbers
that the government's forced upon us
so if you look at our figures for 2030
on a baseline data of existing houses in
that document that TDC had commissioned
those that 2013 uh increase in housing
represents a 25 increase in our housing
within within uh than it if you look at
the 2040 if we if we're forced to have
the extra 4 500 I think it is that's a
32 increase now I think you can
automatically assume that that those two
percentages will be a third a 25 and a
32 increase
in water resources and the production of
waste water all of which has to be dealt
with and I don't think I was very good
at trying to explain what I was talking
about
so we've got extra pressure on a system
that is already collapsing okay which is
our first issue then we've got
discharges and I understand the
discharges we've got a big tank that
when it rains
the big tank fills up because that's a
holding tank and because it fills up we
have to release our Southern water have
to release sewage into the sea
so let's imagine we've got a tank that
feels up to that level on an average day
okay I'm trying to be as simple as I
possibly can because
if we increase the the use of by 25 or
32 if these numbers are forced upon us
then that tank on an average day will I
assume will be used or the the
percentage of use of of production of
waste water or use of fresh water will
be increased by 25 or 32 because people
live in those houses
that means the trigger point when it
rains is reached quicker because the
Tank's Fuller already or or the the
capacity is is greater being used in
that system
what I also need to say is if we looked
at that one development last night that
one little development
we had and it is pretty shocking when
you have somebody on planning that says
it's just grass and that was another
development that is now entirely covered
in cement act and buildings and and
non-porous issues we are taking Farmland
which is naturally porous
where if it rained that rain would fall
onto the ground and seep through our
chalk our chalk strata into the aquifer
and we're covering that land which was
porous in non-porous tarmac non-porous
houses were interrupting the natural
flow of water into the natural system
and we're forcing it into a man-made
system so from our guttering into our
drains and into our sewage system
we don't see any planning applications
with gray water harvesting with porous
roads with porous Pavements if we don't
start addressing some of these issues
which are long-term issues then the only
thing that's going to happen is we are
going to have more residents sat here
moaning about sewage in our seas and
moaning about either not having water
because the system has collapsed or
the system not being able to deal with
the the amount of sewage that needs to
be treated and the figures are pretty
Stark if we have a 25 increase in
housing by 2030 and we're covering more
porous land with non-porous stuff then
we are going to have a serious problem
and I don't know how we deal with this
but burying our heads in the sand are
not challenging Southern water and not
trying to change our planning is not
going to help is it
[Music]
councilorowing thank you very much for
that
um I don't mean this to sound
patronizing at all but I believe I've
given you a considerable amount of
leeway to broaden the subject a bit from
where we started largely because I think
it's good for there to be a big picture
painted from time to time so I hope
other panel members won't mind me giving
you the the time to do that and to cover
some of these issues it does show that
it
at least as far as this council is
concerned it involves more than one
Department more than one group more than
one committee perhaps we'll come back
onto that uh in a few months but thank
you very much for that
um members are there any other comments
yes councilor Thomaston please uh thank
you chair
um following up on Council of wings
um mentioned about the planning and so
forth as chair of planning I brought
this up about southern water over not on
every occasion when I have a meeting
with Mr Livingston
um and you're right it's not statutory
but there is concern as being stated one
of the things which
I think and totally understand the
concern of loss of water we all need
water and so on
but everything hesitate in the ground
has a time limit and I think we're
seeing
I'm saying than it because that's where
I live
um it's not just water
um we've got issues in Margate in other
towns in thanic with gas everything is
falling into pieces in the road
there's been there hasn't been you know
the maintenance
um until something goes wrong
I mean many years ago I used to work on
the electricity board and that was a
long long time ago on the Underground
cables luckily
um they seem to last longer but I think
we're in that situation where
it's happening and of course we don't
want it to happening but um we don't
know something's going to go wrong until
it does go wrong if I'm making sense but
I totally understand what is being said
here and uh
to say to do maintenance on these pipes
pumps
whatever
quite a difficult one to know when
something is going to go wrong but let's
say I totally understand concerns
thank you coach Thompson yes
thank you chair
um you raised three points uh that
should go forward and one of those
points was actually about a public
meeting
I think to get Southern water there I
couldn't agree more with that but the
problem I found I went to a public
meeting uh with the in broadstairs with
solid water
consulate Yates was there Wing was there
uh
and um
that meeting was to impart knowledge to
everyone there
if we have a public meeting for the
residents of for your your estate which
I should think you're entitled to will
certainly but the problems you've
suffered
um that should be for southern water to
impart the information so they could
understand going forward what it will be
it shouldn't be a beating that gets
hijacked for political purposes and
reasons now the meeting I attended was
hijacked by a KCC counselor who was
handing out literature political
literature there and I think that should
be made very clear
that if that happens that person should
be removed from the meeting and all the
literature as well
thank you
thank you very much Council town and I
think most of us would share your
concerns about meetings being hijacked
thank you chair yeah I'd just like to
say um these events have caused such an
impact on residents I think the time now
is for southern water to act and and so
rather than words we want actions and I
fully support the uh this matter to be
brought back to OSP and we invite
Southern water to talk to us a meeting
with the public is a good idea but it's
certainly Time for Action because this
has gone on for so long now and it's
just one thing after another it it's
it's not long before you know
everybody will be affected by these
problems so um yeah let's get Southern
water to answer some questions and start
um sorting things out thank you
thank you very much Council Curry
Council fellows yeah thank you chair
um we all Take a Walk for granted
obviously but um
thought of not being able to have a
shower in the morning but it fills my
OCD with Dread and I just
feel for the people aboard today's and I
just I just wanted I'm not sure I want
to ask I think I'm going to ask Chris
Blundell actually is it in his role as
the acting deputy chief executive is
anybody speaking to Southern water when
these events are happening to ask them
what the hell is going on
because it just seems to I didn't
realize there had been so many and it
seems you know such a regular occurrence
oh thank you for the question counselor
um
when these events happen there are
protocols that are set up across the
district with the relevant agencies
without being too derogatory about some
water they're quite often absent from
the table in terms of
um when we're wanting to have these
conversations with them they often don't
attend the meetings that have been set
up
um
and they can be
lacking in terms of the engagement that
we have with them
so are they just a standalone body with
no one to answer to Is it us they
answered is it KCC they answer to the
Department of environment who do they
answer to
a as a without without using Council
benefits words exactly but they're um
they're a private company ultimately and
they've got the the regulatory framework
around you've got the office uh off what
I believe it is that will be considering
their performance but that ultimately
they're accountable to the government I
would say in terms of the management of
water water companies we can only sort
of ask for engagement with them as a
local Authority
thank you both very much
I wonder if I could ask I'm not sure
whether it be yourself uh Mr Blundell or
whether whether it would be yourself who
could give us some advice on one
particular issue
um clearly the uh matter of compensation
is an important one I just want to try
and get an idea as to whether or not
the council
has any right or responsibility to get
involved in compensation claims which
are largely for individuals are we are
we allowed to do that
or would it be our role to ask for a
general explanation of compensation so
that we don't get drawn into
acting as a kind of Agents or go between
I'm sorry if that sounds like I'm
playing uh devil's advocate here but I'm
just wondering about the business of
compensation where would we stand
lawfully legally within that and I'm
sorry I'm not sure which of you to ask
about that I can just give a general
answer
um Chris explained that they aren't a
statuto body so they're a private body
and if they do come to the table for
discussions then we can have that
discussion about compensation the
general discussion
um we're limited in our powers to force
them to make any decisions about
compensation
thank you very much that's very helpful
an option here to add
the interruption of water supply
Southern water to the overview and
scrutiny panel work program for 2022-23
and invite Southern water to the March
panel meeting
or an option
not to add that item to the work program
but to agree on a different course of
action regarding this matter
for myself I think the compensation
is a that will unfold fairly quickly
hopefully the longer term structure and
strategy might take a bit more than
uh the
three and a half weeks or so that are
left before the next meeting so could I
offer an option to March or April
that's option one or of course the other
option is to agree on a different course
of action entirely okay
like uh just to say um I I think don't
give the option of March or April I
think we invite them to march
okay
I'll second that chair
okay so the the option then is to invite
them to the March meeting which is March
the 14th
can I have a show of hands members
okay that's unanimous we will take that
course of action please
um
and I'm guessing that that would involve
the leader and
um cabinet members as well as officers
to be invited as well to attend I
realize it's it's going to be after
hours
um but we need to set up
a proper
opportunity for them to do that count to
the bayford yeah
I'm not sure part of this process really
but I mean one of the things I would
have thought was quite important and
bring people along then they're going to
have a fairly limited amount of time
with us I think that the questions to be
asked need to be advised to them and
maybe the panel should decide which of
those are most important one of the
things I would say she starts talking
about compensation I don't know if
anybody saw Southeast today I think it
was last night and they were talking
about compensation and if it's not a
conversation about that you get into the
fact that
um if there's decided it's unusual
weather the compensation payments which
are laid down statutory don't have to be
paid and the people that decide whether
the weather's bad enough or not are the
water companies so I'm not sure how sort
of useful at this question about
compensation would be I would have
thought the questions about you know
infrastructure and what they're doing
for the future and that was important
but I would have thought if the panel
could come up with sort of one two three
questions and give them Advanced
knowledge otherwise you've also got the
option they come along and say well
didn't actually prepare for that
question but there's one I will talk
about
to be specific about what it is we want
to become Council of these
yeah thanks chair I think probably just
in response to that I I would prefer to
go down the route of these are the
broader subjects that we're going to be
asking questions about because you know
I it may well come to me two hours
before the meeting that actually this is
a really Salient point that needs to be
asked and then we lose that opportunity
so I would prefer to go down the route
of you know if we're going to do that
here is X Y and Z subject and we submit
that to them
thank you for that of course what we
don't want to do is overload the plate
with too many questions so that no
specific questions are addressed
specifically I think that's the point
that you were making cancel the eight
[Music]
um yeah just to say that southern Wars
should hope you be watching this live
stream or watching it on playback so I
think they'll know exactly what the
topics are and um
as
um
that we can only hope that they will
actually come having watched this
meeting and with the answers to hand
because otherwise why are they why would
they already agree to be coming to know
you excuse me meeting so
I don't think we we need to be like too
precise because if they're doing their
job they should be watching this meeting
right now thanks
or perhaps being encouraged to watch the
recording of it at the later date if
they are in fact absent from the virtual
table as well
um so thank you for that
um March the March meeting is not too
far away so that needs to be done
specifically do you
um
I'll need to get the protocol correct on
this one
um would it be the leader of the council
who writes to them and asked them would
it be me or should it be the cabinet
member with responsibility for that so
that
the person doing the writing is the
person within the council who uh who has
responsibility for that
I think the task lies with you as
chairman of the overview panel who is uh
it's the panel that has decided to
invite Southern water and and the
signature and the invitation should come
from you you may want to seek support
from the lead officers senior officers
been in putting together that draft
letter
thank you
thank you very much for that advice we
will do that then and of course it is
worth noting that these things are
ongoing and I do know that the leader
and officers are in regular contact with
Southern water so efforts are being made
so sometimes
um the these meetings they move much
slower than actual life itself and
hopefully that's one of the things that
will happen here that that events will
overtake the meetings but we will do
that
um and everybody you're welcome members
if you've had particular points you wish
to raise if you contact me within the
next let's say by uh Tuesday
with specifics then I can try and make
sure that we get the letter phrased in a
way that that meets your requirements
thank you very much for your input we've
now move then to agenda item number six
the corporate
performance for Quarter Two And speaking
under rule 20.1 uh we have councilor
Whitehead please
thank you chair
the back or is that just me
just me okay
um
in relation to housing there are areas
of concern which have been well
discussed across many previous meetings
as an ongoing area of concern the number
of households in temporary accommodation
has increased from 115 in June 2021 to
195 now which I believe reflects
external pressures and property
inflation rather than housing
performance and will hopefully be
addressed by further growth of the
in-house temporary accommodation service
but in terms of empty properties brought
back into use there does seem to have
been a significant drop recently down
from 45 to 35.
I'm not certain whether this links to a
monitoring change or is simply a general
decrease
if the latter I was wondering whether
overview and Scrooge Symphony would
consider it useful to advertise the work
of no use empty more so that homeowners
are away aware of the range of help
available to bring properties back into
use
also just as a matter of note the
pollinators and Open Spaces graph seems
to be the same as the trees graph so I
was wondering if we have the information
relating to pollinators and open spaces
available tonight thank you
thank you very much councilor Whitehead
I'm now going to ask Chris Blundell if
he'd like to present his report and and
there may be some answers that you have
to those points already
indeed thank you chair
um so I'm standing in for our director
of communications Hannah Thorpe tonight
unfortunately she's unwell so she's not
able to make it she has prepared a
script for me to run through tonight
um I will do my best uh to present the
reports and answer any questions uh that
the committee may have so as the report
sets out as part of the council's
corporate performance process 39 key
performance indicators are monitored to
provide an indication of how the council
is performing they do not look at every
aspect of the council services and the
data that the council collects but
provide an overview of progress against
the council's key corporate priorities
individual teams and services track
other indicators at a service level
which are not reported on corporately
the data for most of the corporate
indicators is now available live to view
on our website which members can see at
any time it has been agreed that six
monthly reports on a council's corporate
performance will be shared with the
committee overview and security panel to
provide an opportunity for members to
more closely review the direction of
travel of our key service areas
this will allow sufficient Time for
Action and issues to be resolved between
committee meetings and as the data for
the corporate performance indicators are
now available to view on the website at
any time
this report identifies the data as at
the end of quarter two July to September
2022 the data is captured within a new
format which is explained within
paragraph 2.4 of the report
in addition to the summary the more
detailed graphs are also presented in
Annex one they're provided to give a
wider view of the direction of travel
for each indicator
the intention is sorry my apologies the
intention is to return to the overview
and scrutiny panel after the election
setting out the position as at the end
of quarter four so that would be the
performance
we'll make sure that the reports are
timed earlier in the year so that
members are discussing data when it is
more up to date
um in in relation to
um your uh precise questions counselor
um
I can't I'm afraid I I can't comment on
the data that you're referring to in
terms of the the trees and the
biodiversity indicator I'm not for I can
I can see from what the charts are
showing there is an issue in terms of
the data that's been presented I'm
afraid I don't have the answer to that
at hand in terms of the pollinators but
we can get a written response to
um in terms of the numbers of residents
in temporary accommodation that is
something that clearly is a priority for
the whole Council financially I can
obviously comment on that in the terms
of strain that we've seen on our budgets
and that's being reflected in next
year's budget in terms of additional
money we're putting in to Temporary
accommodation and also the investment
that we're looking to make into the
provision of our own units going forward
um but happy to that probably answer
your question fully I'm afraid but I'm
happy to to answer any supplementary
questions or any other questions that
the committee may have
come so I did
no that's fine obviously I understand
the circumstances arounding this
um
yeah in relation to empty homes do you
know if there has been a change in
recording or whether we are just
seeing a drop
coming back into use again I'm sorry I'm
not I'm not familiar enough for the data
sets probably a question I'll need to
refer on to Mr Bob Porter to answer that
question and get a response back to you
Sally I know that's not your specific
service area either so it'll be one that
wanted to get back to you I'm afraid
yeah no that's fine thank you
thank you very much Cassie Gates
um yeah I think thanks chair
um again this might be a tough question
uh considering circumstances so
um 2.19 of the report
um
summary table of performance for
indicators tracking the corporate
priority which is efficiency
um number of complaints
um has increased from 45 to 113 which is
looks like it's the actual maximum we've
ever received so it's record higher
number of complaints
um do you know what these complaints are
in regards to
thanks
sure
um we have a obviously we're we're as a
local Authority we provide a wide range
of services and we get complaints
covering the whole Spectrum
um from Miss Burns to housing placements
to fly tipping
um very topical at the moment
um so I know I know in terms of the
complaint number we've actually gone
through
um a bit of a a real purge and thrown a
lot of uh resources that that recently
and our our complaints numbers are well
down on the data obviously that's
presented in this report because it's
showing information at the end of
September I'll be very hopeful when you
look at the next data set and live data
um we'll be able to show a much improved
position
um
doesn't mean that all Resident concerns
have been resolved all I can say is that
we've been able to answer a lot of the
outstanding complaints it was a quite
significant backlog particularly going
back to September last year I think
that's fair commentary in terms of what
the data's showing and what was the
experience in reality but
um complaints I think if I was going to
speak generally a large proportion to
particularly tend to relate to
operational services so I appreciate
I've got the portfolio holder here
because it's something that interfaces
with every resident so miss bins and the
like typically make up the majority when
you're looking at it but obviously it
spans across the whole range of services
that we provide
yeah that's that's good to know thank
you very much
thank you very much
so thank you
well I just agree with Chris I mean I
think a lot of the complaints are about
Op Services but it's about my spins but
one of the things I can recall we
haven't quite finished the year yet but
11 months in the number of Miss bins
this in the last 11 months is probably
over 50 down on what it was before so
there's a huge service improvement so
hopefully as Chris has said complaints
will be going down as well but I'm sure
that observices are in there because you
know it's thing people get very you know
very worked up about you know a Miss bin
is a source of anger and frustration
but also sorry just to add to that just
building one my point it is a service we
provide on a weekly basis to every
household well at least you know across
the district so it clearly has the
ability to generate a large volume of uh
complaints because it has a personal
impact on people's lives if if your bin
isn't collected it can it you know it's
a source of inconvenience at best for a
week or so
yeah
thank you sorry yeah we empty six
million containers every year so I'm
assuming one or two is bound to happen
I tend to work in smaller figures I
think it's about eighteen thousand three
hundred bins a day
but that's a lot of bins but to every
family the bins been missed it is a
problem there are some we know that are
geographical
um Buxton Road in Ramsgate for example
turning into Highbury Gardens almost
impossible to get the new trucks around
there
and for weeks now their bins have been
missed and I get buried with phone calls
it's an important issue that we need to
address and perhaps we need to look up
ways of more people becoming what's
called assisted collection
um it's a keyhole that road and it's
only 20 yards from front to back it's
got some elderly people in there and
that would certainly solve the issue if
the people were given the operators were
given the time but that's a specific one
I don't expect you to comment on
specific ones
sure sorry just sorry to keep banging on
about bins but since we're talking about
it there is an actual indicator for if
you look at page 42 of the agenda pack
we've got percentage of properties with
bins collected successfully I mean the
numbers are I think are quite remarkable
when you see we think about the volume
we're dealing with
99.7 success rate I mean for any other
uh industry or organization that was the
Staggering success rate in terms of
level of failure versus throughput
I've got to get them in the right order
Council avoid
thank you this is just a sneaky one just
to follow on from what councilor Yates
has said
um obviously we're seeing the the
complaints figures
is there a ballpark Fifth and this won't
be for Chris to answer I don't think
anyway but if you can send it on to
poorly Hannah that'd be great
um is there a ballpark figures to it the
amount of complaints that is expected
obviously no organization is perfect you
are going to get complaints and I also
wondered if there's a flip side to this
as well as to
has the increase
potentially shown that maybe it's a much
easier process for residents to air
their concerns and give feedback just as
a because I like to be a bit optimistic
um but I just wonder whether there was a
bit more detail in that that perhaps
might cast a bit of light and what's
going on
um Chef through you
um in terms of
benchmarking it's very difficult to say
what is a ultimately should always be
our Target should be zero complaints but
that's some sort of utopian world that I
don't we're ever really going to operate
in given the circumstances that you know
just the world we operate in it's
important to say that in general the way
our data is presented we don't set
targets anymore that was a one of the
sort of key decisions that was made in
terms of how we're looking and managing
performance very much now looking at
Trends rather than how far we are above
or below targets because there can be
sort of perverse
incentives or weird outcomes if you set
targets can drive behavior in ways that
you wouldn't necessarily want it to
um but we can certainly track the
direction of where complaints have gone
over the last
few years or period of time and I can
give you a breakdown we've got a break
we track it by service area so if it's
something committee would might see a
little bit more around in terms of
complaints data we could bring that
forward and show you how complaints have
tracked against different service areas
over the last well I'll have to have a
look at the data but of a relevant
period of time
thank you very much
thank you chair I was going to ask
another probably impossible for a Chris
to answer question which follows on from
cancer boys which is about the business
about the residence perceptions of value
for money which doesn't look great and
how that compares with previous years or
how that compares with benchmarking with
other councils
the valley for money is a difficult one
because it's subjective to a degree
um in terms of
um whether
um
um whether a resident thinks the council
offers value for money it's something
that I have actually worked with Hannah
because we asked as part of the
residence surveys it's directly linked
actually in terms of
um the council tax to be charged and
where the residents think that that
offers Valley for money
um again we haven't got benchmarking
data to hand and a different councils
ask the questions slightly differently
which can lead to a a different response
but value for money if I'm if I recall
correctly
um had been improving in recent years
and I think it plateaued in the last
year or so
um
but again that's something I can get
Hannah to provide an answer in terms of
it's it's something we look at and we
analyze
um
when we get the resident survey results
so I can certainly arrange for a
response to be handled there the other
thing to bear in mind this is probably a
little bit uh territory a little bit
more comfortable for me in terms of
council tax not all authorities have us
we'll set the same level of council tax
and that can just be because of the
where the finances are set London
borough authorities are renowned for
having much lower levels of council tax
than other types of authorities and it's
just because of the peculiarities of the
way local authorities are financed so
it's it's not necessarily A fairer
question to compare one authority to the
other because of the particular
circumstances
sorry that's probably crushed and dodged
rather than answered so
planes because
it's definitely a reduction in the
complaints to us so if you go to bins
but I'm just wondering whether when a
complaint comes in whether we actually
either speak to the cruise or speak to
the residents themselves to ask why they
think their Bim was missed and whether
there's a solution so four streets which
have been a bit of a problem in central
Harbor have been because I've not had a
complaint for weeks I would say the
whole of 2023 it was Ashburnham Road and
Spencer walk where two Crews met in the
middle and collected bins and it was the
houses in the middle that were being
misted on Spencer Street there's a
Bollard a little Bollard in the road
which is the guiding Point residents are
telling me and then on Townley Street it
I waited for the cruise because they'd
missed it for three I think for three
weeks about two years ago so I waited
for the crew and the crew told me they
just can't get around the corner because
they're parked cars so very often I
think when a plank complaint comes in do
we deal with it or do we actually say to
the residents or talk to the crews and
say why is the bin call constantly
missed and that very often the residents
even know why the Bin's been missed or
they know the solution to the bin not
being missed in the future so I just
wondered if do do we sort of look at
that aspect of a complaint I'm mindful
I'm talking about a lot about Bing
collection I've got the portfolio holder
sat next to me probably knows more about
it in general terms I think any feedback
from residents is useful for us to
understand service failures or just
general feedback in terms of performance
the other thing to bear in mind in terms
of Miss bins I think that's helped us
improve performance is the bar Tech
system that we've got now in terms of
we've so we have cameras on the
Freighters that allows us to document
and record where the bins were actually
presented for collection previously we
didn't have that sort of evidence could
document whether a Bim was there and it
led to some contention perhaps between
the service and the the residents that's
a really useful tool for us now and the
in-cab technology for the driver to
Market say that Ben was in our in or out
again gives us much greater visibility
of actually what we've guarded and
better record keeping
um but it's probably better if I defer
to the portfolio holder in terms of
um anything that's specific to um sort
of the way a particular Street or I
don't want to get too involved in the
details of that but council bayford did
you understand us that you want to add
yeah I mean the fact is that obviously
the service attempts to do the best job
it can can't always do it
um I know that there has been a change I
think there's been a lot more
supervision that has got involved and
supervisors do in fact talk to Residents
where there are particular problems
um I think there were issues when at one
stage the complaints would just come
straight through to the sort of
complaints handlers which tended to be
on you know exact secretaries doing
doing the job and they weren't in fact
equipped to be able to answer
specifically about things so got stock
answers and people are already angry
because the Bin's been missed and
whatever and somebody's sort of saying
well I don't know but I'll find out and
then go going off and having to find out
I think that that's changed
supervisors are much more involved now
bartek's been been mentioned
we haven't done it yet but I'm advised
that we should be in a position in at
some stage to be able to go back to
these people claim their bins been
missed when we know the bin wasn't out
there you know we've got CCTV on the
wagons and we can do that unfortunately
um the service has to operate at such a
a sort of level of efficiency that it it
can't really spend too much time doing
some of these extra things so in some
respects it's sort of easier to to sort
of you know not go back and say oh Mrs
Jones you know our vehicle was down
there at you know seven o'clock and your
Bim wasn't you know
um but you know we're looking at sort of
trying to address the really tricky ones
I mean you've talked about specific
roads I know in fact that Mark greenian
personally has gone out to meetings at
various roads and it is very very
difficult
um what I would say is that you know
there is no advantage to to the cruise
missing bins you know they get their
collars felt when we get these reports
coming in
um you know and bartek actually gives us
the evidence to sort of say well you
know you should have been able to
collect that bin and why didn't you
so I think watch this space it's getting
better all the time one thing I would
say is that we've been asked by biotech
if we can send Representatives along to
a conference they're holding as an
example of really good practice because
apparently we use this system far more
effectively than other local authorities
that pay for it and I say this this drop
in in Miss bins is and it you know proof
of that really
almost tempted to ask you if you could
say that a bit louder
yes cancer Curry
thanks chair as we're talking about
beans and I'm at cliftonville West
counselor I I couldn't be left out I'm
afraid but what I'm going to talk about
is recycling
um yeah I've noticed um our recycling
rates uh we started off from a 30 level
we seem to be up to about 34.5 I have
seen all the new recycling bins along
the high streets which are fantastic
um really are making a difference I did
speak to Mark Greening and they are
being used and more people are realizing
there's there's mixed recycling on their
High streets uh tin glass plastic
we're a little bit short on on areas
where people can recycle paper and card
but really good to see these containers
that are being used I just wanted to ask
you councilor bayford is there um a
recycling percentage that we're aiming
at
um it'd be nice to get this uh figure up
and I'm sure it will help with all these
communal bins but I just wondered if
there was a figure that we were looking
at or that we had to achieve
uh to my shame I can't give you that
figure I mean all I can tell you is that
obviously the higher recycling rate we
can get the better it is
um but again you know there's quite a
lot of misunderstanding about recycling
as well you know I mean uh we get quite
a few irate people saying oh you know we
want a recycle but but we can't you know
I can't send a wagon down but you know
that the cost of recycling in some cases
is really prohibitive you know the cost
of doing it wouldn't be rewarded by the
return we get but obviously we are
looking to do that and there are some
places where uh I'm for instance
we've got a cancer Huxley here when we
got one road where we don't collect food
waste the residents are very upset about
that but it will be very expensive to
arrange to do it
um I I would say that that you know Mark
greenin I think is doing a first class
job I mean I think he's very much on the
ball
um he's very aware of you know the need
to get the recycling up one point in in
passing it might be worth mentioning
um we often get complaints about lack of
collecting of recycling from uh communal
bins you know where there are blocked
flats and things like that and the main
reason we don't collect it is that the
recycling gets contaminated when it's
contaminated it's down to the management
company of the block of flats to deal
with it not down to us
chair so if I could just add to that
further as well
um
I think it's fair to say our our rate is
lower than other authorities in terms of
recycling
um there for the reasons uh Council
bayford set out sometimes there are
significant cost implications of
addressing that we've also got
demographic challenges in terms of
deprivation which has been shown to
correlate with lower recycling rates
some of the
geographical topographical issues in
terms of getting the vehicles around
narrow streets and like can cause
problems we're aware that the
environment Act is likely to set higher
targets that would be bound to achieve I
think I've been doing a quick Google
because I couldn't remember these app
figure if my Googling is accurate it
beats 65 by 2035 so that's a that's a
radical shift change in terms of where
we are now and we would require a not
only an investment in resource in the
service but a change in service can be
figuration if we're going to be able to
achieve the targets that are set out in
that act
thank you councilor hutchi
thanks chair I think at the moment it's
50 plus that each Council should be
recycling that's targeting as you say
it's going up and then things like food
waste I think by about 2025 TDC should
be collecting all domestic food waste
all domestic food waste
so that where the money's coming from to
do that I don't know but that's what's
good so the you know the environment
bill is pushing the levels up some
councils get to about 80 percent
recycling so I can't remember which ones
but you know that's good so you know
there's a lot of scope for us to do
better thanks
thank you very much everyone for all the
comments
um thank you councilor Baker for being
here and taking uh ad hoc questions if
like that because I know I wasn't uh
expecting you and but thank you so much
for facilitating the discussion so uh
members we're asked unless there are
specific recommendations you wish to
make we are asked to note this latest
performance report for quarter number
two are we happy to do that
thank you very much
thank you again moving on then to agenda
item number seven
and before I call on uh Sally O'Sullivan
to introduce the report uh councilor
Whitehead speaking under rule 21.1
please
[Music]
thank you chair
genuinely brief statements to say that I
welcome this report and the huge amount
of effort that has gone into bringing
all actions up to date since housing was
brought in-house
I know how much effort it has taken from
housing and significant progress has
been made across an exceptionally
difficult time
I would also like to say that I welcome
the further contract to speed up the
commendable progress on eicrs thank you
thank you very much uh Charlie
O'Sullivan please
thank you chair
um first this is my Corsa 2 report not
quarter one which I think of in the
notes that's probably my fault sorry
um overall our performance remains
steady with areas that we are actively
working on to see further improvements
um for our compliance update most of our
work streams are operating as business
as usual now and areas where we're
struggling to improve are as follows
Legionella actions where we've got 13
actions still outstanding these are due
to no access to properties
fras where we have a total of 111
actions outstanding with 67 overdue we
continue to make progress with actions
but this is stored because our project
surveyor that was working on this has
unfortunately left and they were
dedicated to carrying out a majority of
them
we are disappointed that the domestic
electrical safety compliance is at 91.3
and hasn't really moved further forward
eicrs are being completed for example 88
were completed in September and this is
indicative that Mayors are keeping on
top of the current program but cannot
cope with anything over and above
to address this we're procuring our own
contractors that be ready to start in Q3
and mirrors have taken on further
contractor to meet current demands to
end that on a high note gas compliance
remains at 100 percent
our operational performance
um our gas cause performance remains
steady customer service stats have
declined but we believe this is due to
the low amount of returns which screw
figures rather than actual performance
this contract is coming to an end in
2023 therefore the rate of returns for
surveys is something we'll pick up with
a with the new contractor as part of the
new contract
Miss continues to perform well even
though customer satisfaction has dropped
the score is still very high at 90 and
the quality of workmanship is confirmed
by our post inspections
a new set of kpis have been agreed as
part of the contract extension with Miz
which will be until March 2025 and this
should help drive performance
our Capital program spend is a bit low
for this time of year we would rather it
be nearer around 50 at that point
but Capital program progress is going as
we would hope where we've been unable to
spend monies on the kitchen bathroom
contract where the contractor went into
administration at the end of q1 and
where we are mobilizing the window
replacement program and haven't spent
any money yet
this also has an impact on our void's
performance as you can see performance
fell in Q2 because Mia's diverted
resource from the voids team to finish
the outstanding kitchens and bathrooms
where the contractor down tours Midway
through
Mayors have employed another
subcontractor to provide additional
resource so we can see improvement over
the so we hope to see improvement over
the second part of the year
finally I'll repeat a rears percentage
has increased during Quarter Two And
this is of no surprise considering
what's happening nationally what is
reassuring those that even though
arrears have increased in this quarter
in comparison to this time last year and
the year before there is an overall
reduction
we've also reached out to neighboring
local authorities and find that we are
all experiencing the same kind of
increase in arrears
what is positive is that residents are
engaging really well with us as we have
had an increased referrals to our
financial well-being team
are there any questions
thank you very much Sally members
Consortium
I just want to say thank you and how
impressive it is to get this level of
detail it really is very reassuring and
even where you can see that there's
maybe not not the progress that you were
hoping to make to have the explanation
as to why is is really helpful thank you
thank you very much members unless there
are specific recommendations we wish to
make we are asked to note oh I'm sorry
Council King didn't see you
accounts definitely not counselor King
unless I've changed my hair
um
it's catching that
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
thank you for your report Sally as ever
um just want to ask a question on
the day-to-day responsive repairs in
mirrors and whether you could just
expand a little bit more
um on for the last two quarters the
Urgent jobs percentage completed on time
has has dropped
um so it was 100 Q3 and 4 but Q one and
two it's 97
um for both q1 and Q2
um
and I think that but then obviously
average days to complete non-urgent
works is improving
um so I just wonder if you can just
expand a bit more about that in terms of
because they kind of conflict each other
in terms of urgent and non-urgent
sorry part of the reason why we have
changed the kpi suite which will what
this indicates is some of the jobs that
are going overdue but we're not properly
capturing and also jobs that go overdue
and across periods as well which is
difficult to kind of quantify in terms
of how the kpis are currently laid out
so I believe
I believe that in actual fact that more
jobs are being completed and this is
kind of indicative of the of we have got
less jobs that are currently in the
works in progress so live jobs have
reduced which means more jobs are being
completed quicker
um but I'm not sure why the Urgent jobs
are showing as coming down right now but
I can definitely I can find out for you
one of the kpis we're introducing is the
amount of jobs that are going overdue
and that should of course drive
performance because we should never have
jobs over over June of course we will
give them a little bit of a leniency
either side
um but that would hopefully where these
don't capture the statistics
particularly well that would hopefully
show why we're not why that why that
figure has come down if that makes sense
all right
thank you very much
members are we happy to know the report
there in the comments thank you very
much indeed
agenda item number eight HRA tower
blocks refurbishment and retrofit
program before I invite Sally O'Sullivan
to bring us a report once more we turn
to councilor Whitehead please under rule
20.1
huge and entirely necessary undertaking
and I've spoken of its importance in
earlier meetings
I have also raised my concerns in
relation to whether the social housing
decarbonization fund will provide
sufficient support for us to do what we
need to do across stock long term
but this is a necessary start and the
tower blocks are also exactly the right
place to begin this considering the
level of need in terms of structure and
Energy Efficiency
I would like to say a huge thank you to
all the officers involved in making
these bids they know how time consuming
they are and I hope that we achieve the
results that we need to thank you
thank you very much Council Whitehead
salio Sullivan please thank you
um okay so this report gives more detail
on the funding of this project and how
we will award contracts and the
Personnel required to mobilize the
contracts we want to take advantage of
the funding opportunities available to
us to deliver approximately 17 million
pounds worth of work these Works will
improve fire safety with the replacement
of the external wall insulation improve
structural safety by carrying out any
concrete repairs required improve Energy
Efficiency with a number of proposed
retrofit measures including replacing
windows and Heating
improving the condition of the blocks
with cyclical works that include
decoration to internal areas repair
decorate or replace flooring and the
refurbishment of balconies
the founding allows us to carry out all
of these works at once reducing cost and
disruption to residents for example
using the current estimates external
funding will a pay for approximately 70
of the cost of the project with 30
coming from the HRA budget
our Focus has been on speed of delivery
for this project to ensure we remain
eligible for the funding we have applied
for hence the route to Market we have
selected and the partnering contractors
we have selected as the report explains
this report gives further detail on the
works we intend to undertake the costs
of the work and the ancillary costs of
running the project and the different
funding streams to demonstrate the value
for money that can be achieved with this
route
there are any questions
thank you very much counseling
I've just got one actually I'm so glad
the work's been done and thank you for
sourcing the money because I know it's
been quite complicated hasn't it trying
to go through all this but the one thing
I wanted to do in Harbor Towers we've
got a combination of homeowners and uh
tenants
uh will there be any cost to those
people that actually own their own homes
to any aspect of any of the work that
will be done and
and will will there be some sort of
consideration of uh
the homeowner's ability to actually pay
that money given that in Harbor Towers I
know that some of the residents are
elderly
and not working
okay thank you
um yes there will be a cost to
leaseholders
um as I've as I've said about 70 percent
in this current estimate
um will be covered with grant funding
um and leaseholders will not be will not
have to pay for anything that's covered
by grants
um the the uh EWR the it's so award
replacement which is being fully funded
by homes England and that is done so
that leaseholders are not impacted
financially is is quite a large
proportion of this work
um for the application of social housing
decarb fund
um the they won't pay for the part that
is funded
um the leaseholders are entitled to some
infill works with with the social
housing decaf fund and also with this
funding leaseholder contribution is
capped and working with the legal team
right now is to exactly what the cap is
and how we would apply that
with the cyclical works as with all
cyclical works we have to um
leaseholders have to pay
their percentage that they would owe as
per their lease a leasehold agreement
um but with if you remember with Royal
Crescent we put a um
a report to cabinet which asked cabinet
to approve if we could set a
um the figure against against the
property so they didn't have to pay at
that time and that would be on a
case-by-case basis now if we as we get
further down this line if that is
appropriate we could approach cabinet
again to see if that is something that
we can do for these leaseholders
regardless where we do have high service
charges leaseholders can approach us for
a repayment
agreement rather than having to pay it
off all at once
yeah
counselor Huxley please
thanks chair thanks Sally it's a big bit
of workers Council Whitehead has said
massive
um just a couple questions
um you talk about how batar's been
retrofitted
what about Brunswick court it's exactly
the same size I know we talked about it
a long time ago it's the same size same
number of flats I think built at the
same time
why isn't that being retrofitted and
good news you're saying you'll report
that local people probably get
apprenticeships and works at join the
building which I think is great so they
get training and things like that so
that's excellent and are there any
penalty fees on mares if they don't
deliver on time and to the budget that
you set
thank you
okay um so if I start off with uh your
question about Brunswick Court
um so Brunswick Court was left out of
this specific program because it doesn't
have external wall insulation that needs
to be replaced immediately whereas the
other blocks do and this we five tower
blocks was kind of felt like it was
quite a big enough project as it was and
because we're using a blended funded
approach it was easy to run the same
approach across those five Tau blocks
and whereas trying to include Brunswick
into that with a slightly different
approach would have added complexity to
a project which is already highly
complex
um Brunswick will get its turn
um but once once we've got started on
this project and we can start looking at
what other funding opportunities are
coming up through social housing decarb
funding
um and where we will turn to next but
it's it's not forgotten about
um
in terms of penalty fees for Mayors if
they don't deliver on time and on budget
it's
um
reputationally families they've got a
lot at stake here because they are
partnering with us to deliver this and
they know the time scales that are
required to do that
um written into the contracts that we
use do give us the power to apply
penalties if they don't deliver on time
and to budgets but that will all be
driven through the contracts that we use
thank you very much come to the eight
um thank you very much Charlie and um
as I mentioned before this is a really
exciting piece of work
um just one question on kind of
deadlines so we as counselors
um you can obviously speak to you
um and bring you into meetings but what
are the kind of key deadlines
um that are
being set for this project and uh
um how can we kind of
um keep our eye on them to make sure
that we're on track
um going forwards thanks
um so the key deadline will start once
we know if we've been successful in
getting the social housing
decarbonization funding once we know
that we then have a 24 months to deliver
with two months overhang at the other
end to pay off the final invoices
anything that we don't spend out of that
funding that's awarded to us will have
to be returned after that time so that
is what specifically gives our deadline
I've made this into a three-year
contract because obviously things like
the cyclical Works can come outside of
the social housing decarb funding works
so we would obviously front load the
fund The Works that are dependent on the
funding to make sure that we could take
full advantage of that
um to keep this program on track and to
ensure quality and also that the
quantities that we are paying are
correct we are employing a third-party
consultant surveyor to assist us with
that
um they will do all the QSC for us this
is obviously highly complex we don't
have the technical skills in-house to
know the the quality of works that we're
receiving so we need help with that they
will also help us keep this to um to
time as well
can I just ask a supplementary thanks
thanks just
um excuse me if I haven't read if you've
written this down in the report but when
is the funding expect the
when when do we expect to know whether
we've been successful or not
um end of February middle of March ish
thank you come to the town end
do you do your contracts have a
retention clause
yes they will have a retention clause on
there we will hold back 10 percent of
the final figure for one year defect
period
um that would give them that that
obviously incentivizes them to complete
any defects that might occur during the
set that settling one year period after
they've completed works
thank you very much
Council beef
thank you chair
um as as often I do I'd just like to say
thanks to Sally for two very clear and
detailed reports and for her
explanations for statistics and not as
Progressive as we would like them to be
I think this is appreciated by everybody
so thank you
uh members then we are asked to note
this report I'd be happy to do so
thank you very much
we now turn to agenda item number nine
the review of the overview and scrutiny
panel work program
um
do members have any comments
to make on the work program as it sits
before us at the moment
perhaps
um looking at this then on the 14th of
March
we're going to we're going to be writing
to our Southern water
which isn't currently on this printed
format
we've got collaboration working party
report and the review of the program
um
I had
spoken earlier about the possibility of
um
having a
an update on declaring an interest
peculiar or otherwise at meetings there
was a slight breakdown
occurred at the last meeting in that
some with the declared interest to make
were not allowed to speak at all some
with a declared interest rate to make
were allowed to speak and then leave the
room I just wonder whether as a a group
we could ask for
the training post the elections
or if not in April beforehand a serious
update on what declaring an interest
really is what it should be and the
um consequences of so doing I know this
is rather personal to me but I know
there were other counselors who were
involved because a declaration of
Interest was either made or in my case
absented from the meeting because of it
and it was under fees and charges it
meant that they could not vote on any
part of the budget
because
we didn't and I did notice that one time
you did but it meant because the budget
included fees and charges if you follow
the logic of having not been allowed to
vote on it then you shouldn't have voted
on the budget and that disenfranchises I
believe members of this committee
so I'm asking if we think as a committee
we could do with an update on exactly
what we should and shouldn't declare and
whether such a thing in future might
disenfranchise people in terms of voting
on the entire budget itself part of
which of course is fees in charge
yeah I agree chair I think definitely we
should be looking at that I think it was
the craziness of someone having a
parking permit had to just pull out of
the hot voting of the whole budget which
I we're all we're all uh involved in
things in thanetic we're all Council
taxpayers you know we pay Council taxes
does that mean we shouldn't talk about
council tax you know so I think you know
pulling out of the whole conversation of
the budget because you have a car
parking permit was the craziest thing
that we were told to do
well I think as Mr House used to say in
his in his Heyday we all have a special
dispensation uh on things like
allowances and and parking permits I
just one my main question for you
members really is do we try and get an
uh an informative update
for April
or do we
get a substantial update put into the
training program which we know is coming
and some of us have been involved in in
discussions about that
post elections really does does that was
that one of the questions I was just
going to say from the point of view of
the member training group we know that
there is a substantial program planned
and it seems sensible to try to fit that
in there for new members and returning
members and for for that to be clarified
you know on day one as it were up for as
part of the new members training
thank you councilman I mean that is
confusing because I also have a parking
permit but I suspect everybody in this
room has bought a parking ticket
so none of us and I was the one that
went oh my god I've got a parking permit
uh you know if you a parking permit is
exactly the same as any one of us buying
a parking ticket so there are some bits
of declaring an interest that I I it's
really important that interests are
declared but I find really difficult and
actually really not sensible and I did
vote in the other aspects of of that of
that of of that budget meaning like you
notice because what is the fact I've got
a parking ticket got to do with spend on
the pool
the point I was making was that the
budget includes fees and charges and if
you're excluded from any debate or
voting on fees and charges you are
therefore discluded from and and there
were three of us who did where we were
excluded from all of it which I felt
meant I we was personally I was
disenfranchised well I've I used my
common sense and my fairly high
education to to make my own decision
which was I'm not going to vote on fees
and charges but I am going to vote on
the other bits because he's Bonkers
because you would I mean I couldn't
understand why you weren't voting I'm
thinking this is totally disfranchised
and if if if we've all got bought a
parking ticket in the last year then
none of us should have voted on anything
well indeed I I I've got to confess I
was kind of making a point you can't
complain about being disenfranchised
until you have been
um
well surely we've been given the wrong
legal advice haven't we you and you and
you've been given the wrong legal advice
by the TDC legal department
um just a matter of consistency really
there are two issues you either can
speak on something if you declared an
interest and then not take part in the
debate and not take part in the vote or
you can't speak at all but cancer wins
in the full council meeting weren't you
when the fees and charges were talked
about and voted on okay but you were in
the meeting whereas you weren't in the
meeting of the overview in scrutiny
yes yes
so I think if so I think that the view
is we yes Council Thomas
[Music]
um one I I can't agree with counselor
Wing I know he'll shout at me but a
parking ticket and a parking permit to
me is completely different
um I buy parking tickets if I have to
I'm not going to park the car in Clifton
and we'll walk to this office but also
it's something that's concerned and I've
been here a long time now
all of us as we know have their own
interests
in life
and some of those interests can come up
within Council
I think some people might know what I'm
talking about here and recently it
hasn't happened about a certain place in
Margate but
um I've always found that a difficult
one because I have been told just
because you've got an entry you can't be
involved in everything
um but some of the expertise that that
person may have if I'm making sense
could help a committee easy
so it's my personal thoughts
thank you
I would like to come back because
it's a parking permit is still going to
be put up by 10 so that's the bit I
looked at oh well a vote to vote
Mr bundle please I first off I agree
with the the recommendation or the
proposal that is included in training
future for members I think overall
training on
um
registered of interest and the like is
is is what should be happening as part
of the member induction program anyway
particularly new members who wouldn't be
afraid with it but it's also useful to
revisit and clarify what the position is
some guidance around it I think there is
um that it's not always as black and
white when you're looking at your
interests that you've got to consider
whether it affects your
um your financial position your
relatives financial position and there's
a there's some discretion as to whether
a parking permit would that's that's for
someone to ask for a member to make that
decision as to whether it affects their
interests or not because it's not for
officers to tell members to declare an
interest it is for members to decide
whether to come are an interest on or
not and therefore when you're looking at
it you have to decide whether I would
say if you think you are
your decision making is materially
affected by your own person's personal
circumstances that is my view on it I'm
not a lawyer I'm not a constitutional
expert I'm not the monitoring officer
um overall I think it would be very
welcome and worthwhile to get that
training built into the members
induction program post the elections
yes I was just thank you very much for
that I was just conscious of the fact
that there are a lot of subjects and a
lot of information to be taught around
the induction program and
some of that information can be shared
by the more experienced counselors that
will be returning some will some won't
uh and I'm just wondering therefore
whether we try and get an update in
April here or whether we actually leave
it the general consensus seems to be
leave it until the next thing but
perhaps when we speak with Nick Hughes
about the training program we can ask to
make sure that there's a really
substantial
early on isn't it so it would fit in
quite naturally with that I would
well it is there are some uh there are
some really big issues where in my
experience in the last eight years the
council has not had
a set position and it's varied in its
advice
uh depending sometimes on what the
matter at hand is but okay so uh on in
April then we've just we have a Cabinet
member presentation review of the
program and that would be April would be
our last meeting before
the elections so um if there are no more
comments to make on our work program the
next agenda item and item number 10 is
the plan and exempt cabinet report list
do members have any comments they wish
to make about that
Council Austin
Groundhog Day again I'm afraid
um noting that cabinet are about to make
further decisions about
leveling up spend on Ramsgate port and
begging desperately for anything
remotely resembling the level of detail
and information that we've had from
Sally this evening on the massive amount
of spend intended there where we've had
lengthy correspondence with Mr Blundell
about this in the lead-up to the council
meeting which resulted in Council wing
and me feeling that we needed to abstain
because we still do not have that
information we have copies of project
initiation documentation where the risk
assess assessment sections are
completely blank this is really worrying
and
um so we I would like to recommend if we
are allowed to do that to the Future
overview and scrutiny panel uh
post-election that at an early stage
officers are invited back to give us
morning to give future counselors more
information about that because it really
is a great concern that there are these
big decisions being made and yet so
little detailed information on actually
how the money is being spent seems to be
available to councilors thank you
counseling thank you I'll follow on from
Council Austin
on top of that there is a future concern
there's a concern about possible future
liabilities as I said that the residents
of thanet would would foot the bill if
if we if we manage to bring a ferry in
nobody's evidence that the the sort of
the high risk and the low risk of
actually the ongoing cost to us as a
council to actually service that Ferry
coming in as we know trans Europa I
believe left leaving birthing fees it
became it was a clearly uneconomic for
them to operate out of Ramsgate weed
obviously provided the birth provided
the staff in which left us with with
their own liabilities and I certainly
think that as a as a as an elected
person representing the world there but
as you know just as a counselor I'd like
to see those risks modeled
uh what are the future costs we've got
the capital money to perhaps build it so
they will come but what are the ongoing
costs if we actually managed to bring a
ferry in is it sustainable in the in the
long term what are the risks to us as a
council but more importantly what are
the costs like possible possible costs
likely to be for residents if they have
to subsidize a ferry coming into airport
and I've we've not seen first of all
we've not seen any any documentation
that's evidenced whether a ferry is is
viable in our pool and we've not seen
any evidence that models future risk and
that's really worrying
indeed and I uh I can't answer those
questions because we haven't even seen a
document yet that says there is going to
be one coming in so I I don't know but
uh I think I think the point you make is
it is is valid there should be as in all
things more information but sometimes it
really does depend on the structure at
which the council operates I mean we we
are here to scrutinize decisions made by
the cabinet system under which we
operate and we can call in for example
we can invite Southern water in we can
call in people who operate in the area
which has an effect on our residents but
this panel
isn't a um I don't quite know how to say
this but I'm playing Devil's Advocate a
bit this panel isn't a panel for second
guessing and changing decisions and
Minds unless there's a a solid reason
for it uh was it Council Elise
yeah thank you chair um just saying I
agree completely with uh councilor
Austin I think there's a there's a
greater deal that this panel can do in
terms of scrutinizing these decisions
even if we you know sort of disagree
probably with what should be done at the
Port there's a greater deal that that we
as a panel should and could be doing
um and I think we need to be given that
opportunity to do so
any other comments remembers yes yes add
that
um following the council meeting the
other week where councilor uh wing and I
abstained we have been contacted by
councilors from across the chamber and
by a number of residents saying yes they
are worried about this we have a we have
an email in our inboxes which has gone
to the leader and Mr Carmichael from a
resident in our Ward saying why have we
had no updates on this why do we have no
information on this we're residents
we're paying our council tax don't we
deserve this information I think that
there is quite a lot of concern out
there and I think this panel needs to be
scrutinizing those decisions uh quite
closely thank you
foreign
so do you have a specific recommended
are you wanting us to have more
information by April or are you wanting
it to be for the new Council
post-elections to be given
uh a a detailed but big picture analysis
of that piece of real estate and what's
going on or may go on is that what I'd
love us to have more information by
April I don't know how realistic that is
um but I'm sure that those of us who
have who have sat on this panel up to
now would like to be able to to end our
period on it
um by uh by having some information that
would be useful particularly those of us
in his Ward the Ramsgate Port sits
um but so I'd like to say yes please can
we have something for April if for
whatever reason that isn't possible then
to put it perhaps on the forward program
for the for our successes on this panel
thank you and I think it it starts with
a letter to the leader of the council
then really doesn't it from this
committee to the lead of the council
Council townend you know we we talk
about the expense what we're spending
what we don't know how much you're going
to spend or anything like that the point
is that we we talk about ferries coming
into our Port do we know
where these fairies are do we know who
operate them and how much they cost
where are they I mean we talk about
Belgium we talk about Belgium having uh
ferries that operate on the same basis
that we hope to come our way do we know
how much information do we have I've
never heard any information or been
given to me any information
Council town is I think you're right yes
and I think that's the point that was
being made uh Council Wingham I mean you
just said we've got the power to pull
people in to ask for additional
information so is it possible for this
committee to pull the relevant offices
in I mean I did ask that question about
how many don't give me the name of the
ferries because that's commercially
sensitive how many ferries have we got
interested and there's just a waffely
answer uh we need you know we need
concrete concrete a concrete yeah sorry
the pardon the pun uh we need you know I
would love to see a business case you
know I it was once said to me that you
know it's not the responsibility of this
Council to have a business case followed
by you're an inexperienced counselor who
doesn't know what she's doing but I'd
read the local government associations
whole document because I'm an
inexperienced counselor who didn't know
what I was doing which was about
procurement okay and how
if you're going to spend money wisely
you must have a business case now a I
don't know who's driving the drive for a
for a ferry I don't think any of us do
you know I I'll use the analogy with the
airport I'm not a supporter but we know
it's RSP okay we we can see we can see
touch feel and read stuff who is driving
that that who is driving the need for a
ferry where has it come from has it come
from cabinet we know it's not come from
a policy because that was that came out
of the question that was asked here but
there is no policy for a ferry and that
really and it's a it's not just about
the pool I know we focus on the pool
it's about are we doing things right in
other areas you know the whole thing
over the cement Batcher and and births
four or five should be a whole lesson of
learning and and and improving practice
for the future and what I fear is we're
just going to have another thing that is
going to settle residents with
additional costs we need to learn and we
need to make sure we're doing what we
should be doing and you look at the
housing budget and EV the last little
window is evidence the need for it why
it's there why we need to spend it it's
there in that document that's what we
need to see in every every bit of spend
we have that's my opinion anyway
I think it's a valid point I think
there's there's uh you know me Devil's
Advocate again there's a difference
between
what we have to provide by Statute and
what we may or may not provide if we've
got the money I guess but thorough
information you can never have
too much thorough information but you've
got to recognize commercial
sensitivities and all those kind of
things I don't know that we would get
anything on that by April it's not very
far away but
um
um but certainly for the new Council
post
ER thank you
um members will note that on the floor
plan there is the item for the cabinet
decision the future delivery Port of
Ramsgate what this is your main decision
on the direction of the operation
delivery in connection with the leveling
up fund supported by ports
infrastructure project so there is the
opportunity if members so wish to
discuss that at a
um overview and security meeting it
could be called in in time for the
subsequent one subsequent OSP if members
so wish
I am aware that there's a package of
information that's going to be provided
to members in advance of the papers
going out into the public domain
um to fully brief members around the the
context of the decision that cabinet
being asked to make so that my
understanding is the members briefing
will be held first and the papers will
be released subsequent to that as well
but that doesn't obviously negate the
the the the opportunity or the power for
OSP to call in any
um cabinet uh decision if they so wish
thank you very much
yeah come back on that sorry
um just to say um I I think that that
sounds very helpful I think the
difficulty that we have as a panel and
we've had it this evening with the
southern water matter is that we have to
prove that
um cabinets decision making is flawed
and why it's flawed and so on and we
tried that very hard with the southern
water matter and we and it was not
successful
um so I think there is a there is a
procedural issue there that um that we
face that we may be able to to get more
information but hopefully if we get a
members briefing at least we may be able
to ask some more questions and maybe
even get some answers this time
okay members are there any other
comments queries questions you speak
um in that case it's nine o'clock that
clock up there's a little bit fast that
concludes the business of tonight's
meeting and I declare the meeting close
thank you very much for your attendance
and also all the very helpful comments
that came through in the live streaming
will now end